alors le prix est attribué à il y à
l'endroit
et il y à l'envers les médailles sans
connaître la valeur des concours ont à
peu près autant de valeurs comme critère
de sélection pour un consommateur que de
se dire l'étiquette est jolie ça doit
être bon
tout n'est pas la méthodologie tout va
dépendre des juges qui sont habités de
la qualité des juges est ce que le
concours est sérieux est ce que le
concours soit 18 mille échantillons ou
est-ce qu'il en reçoit 500 nadia
fournier ou tristes du guide du vin va
même jusqu'à remettre en cause
l'honnêteté de certains concours moi
j'ai déjà participé à certains concours
auquel je ne repartirai voudrait plus
maintenant parce que on m'a demandé de
modifier la note on a beaucoup insisté
pour modifier la note ça s'est rendu
jusqu'au président du concours qui m'a
demandé modifié ma note et j'ai refusé
évidemment ces petites médailles
brillante attire nos yeux de
consommateurs et oriente parfois nos
choix malheureusement pour les
consommateurs n'y a pas de guide sur les
tablettes à côté des bouteilles pour
dire qu'elles concourent à vraiment une
valeur
il y à des bouteilles qui affichent
parfois jusqu'à quatre médailles il ya
trois médailles de concours il ya une
médaille qui dit finalement que ce vin
lors reçu plus de 200 médaille au
courant des années 2020 il faudrait
vérifier mais
je suis un petit peu suspicieux
j'appelle mon roman own words
jamais entendu parler
je réponds tac pas si c'était bon et si
cétait reconnu ça serait
ces médailles ont un coût les vignerons
doivent payer pour s'inscrire au
concours est payé pour reposer les
médailles sur leurs bouteilles s'ils
gagnent prix
à la sécu les statistiques de ventes de
produits médaillés ne sont pas
comptabilisés il y à une première ligne
qui peut vous permettre d'éviter les
erreurs les conseillers en vin sont
dévoués ils sont à dinan et la plupart
du temps ils sont bien informés tout ce
qui brille n'est par mais on peut quand
même se fier à quelques uns de ces
concours
donc on peut les compter sur les doigts
d'une main il y aurait un week end of
the world qui est l'un des plus reconnus
est en nationalement c'est un concours
sérieux avec des professionnels du vin
plusieurs que je connais d'année en
année plusieurs juges qui ont eux mais
une réputation internationale
il y aurait les vinalies qui sont
toujours assez fiable d'une année à
l'autre il ya le concours du mérite
général agricole à paris aussi se sait
vraiment souvent très fiable maintenant
le seul concours auquel j'accepte encore
de participer en 2021 2022 c'est un
concours de vins canadiens le national
board of canada c'est parce qu'on sait
que les vins sont bien traités et que
les consommateurs en retour ils trouvent
leur compte dans le monde fromage et
beaucoup de concours beaucoup de
médailles aussi mais leur crédibilité et
- remise en cause par yanick jean qui a
été juge lors de nombreux concours
internationaux
parce que le québec a quand même cette
particularité d'avoir une grande
diversité fromagère par rapport à
l'ensemble du canada donc le québec a
toujours été un leader dans la
conception du concours fromagers mais je
vous dirais que c'est surtout l'europe
qui domine par le nombre de concours
[Musique]
créé en 1999 le prix caseus récompense
chaque année plusieurs fromages
québécois au tout début et l'occasion ça
représentait pas grand chose pour le
consommateur c'est beaucoup pour la
commercialisation les résultats du
concours aujourd'hui quasi leçon un
impact au niveau du consommateur de
casillas s'adapte le marché évolue
puisse assez rare dans les concours
qu'on aura une organisation aussi
efficace aussi rigoureuse dans une
évolution qui est aussi rapide on a
acheté à l'épicerie deux produits qui
sont médaillés mais depuis 5 c'est ce
même 8 ans est-ce que vous pensez que ça
encore un impact de le conserver sur
l'étiquette comme ça l'intérêt
d'inscrire les médailles qu'ils ont pu
remporter ça peut être un facteur
décisionnel pour le consommateur qui se
rabat sur l'information qui est sur
l'étiquette donc je pense que dans ce
cas ci ça peut être intéressant de voir
que ces deux produits là ont gagné des
prix à l'international
et puis qui sont vendus ici au québec
donc je pense que oui ça peut être digne
d'intérêt pour ce type de produits
qu'est ce que les médailles auxquelles
vous ne touchez pas non la plupart des
concours je pense qu'ils sont assez
crédible pour pour se permettre d'avoir
ces produits là dans nos magasins
depuis une dizaine d'années il y a eu
une explosion de l'offre des spiritueux
tout aussi intéressants les uns que les
autres il y en a même qui se démarque
sur la scène internationale grâce
justement à des concours ou des
compétitions ici on est rendu à quoi 60
et 50 jeunes québécois laisse au cul
comment faire que le nôtre se démarque
de ses 60 quelques autres là
ces concours sont devenus une véritable
industrie dans leur organisation les
plusieurs concours qui vont offrir des
espèces de sous-produits à côté de dire
donnez nous deux mille dollars on va
vous produire un podcast qui va parler
de votre produit pour 6000 pièces mais
on va vous faire carrément vidéos
youtube qui va parler du produit à
couillet de la qualité mais où il ya du
marketing
si on regarde les vieux produits par
exemple des vieilles bière des fois on a
carrément les médias qui font partie du
design de cette bière leur fait qu'à ce
moment là mais là il ya même plus de
vérification quoi que ce soit qui fait
ça fait partie du design de ce produit
là ça se fait aussi avec le fromage on
cherche le nom du congo pour cette
médaille-là ah ouais
ouais c'est vrai que ça peut porter à
confusion aussi même moi j'arrive pas à
voir bon meilleur cheddar vieilli au
monde on sait pas nécessairement dans
quel concours ce que j'interprète moi
ici c'est que ce produit-là a
probablement gagné un concours une année
on connaît pas l'année on connaît pas le
congo et puis je pense qu'ils sont
rabattus sur cette mention spéciale là
depuis l'on regardé sur leurs étiquettes
pour pour plusieurs années c'est ce que
j'interprète du moins pour un
consommateur à moins de vouloir passer
30 minutes devant une bouteille de vin
pour faire des recherches sur son
téléphone il ya vraiment peu de façon
d'établir avec certitude si ses contours
ont une valable
[Musique]